this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
manscape is the men's premiere brand for
below the waist men's grooming and
shaving
but guys what are you doing after you
shave to seal the deal
introducing the new refined cologne by
manscape
wow damn look at that oh it's nice
gentlemen nice wood top
nice glass square
bottle oh it smells fresh colonga oh
that smells good with the same signature
scent that's an
all manscaped formulas this cologne
is a perfect complement to their
grooming collection
ah i'm getting so late good
yup joe's gonna get laid with me
it's called me inviting and it starts
with a light citrus burst
ending with a woodsy masculine scent
masculine it does smell masculine it's
light
approachable and gentlemanly and all the
right ways
just like my bowels and it's
hypoallergenic cruelty free
dye free paraben free and 100
vegan for the refined cologne and all
your
other manscape grooming products make
sure you go to massgate.com
jk news to get 20 off plus free
international shipping
that's a super good deal thank you
manscaped your body will
thank you
[Music]
throttle you guys know that i love
throttle
waffle sounds like a word from ice cream
flavor sounds like something from rick
and morty
right it does what is it throttle
is three apples it's a three-person
couple there we go
is it what a three-person relationship
oh really that's a throw
a threesome yeah isn't it just a
threesome
the threesome is the actual couple three
cup of throbble
drop
otherwise known as like more mineral
marriages polygamous
yeah when do you become a pimp true wait
what's the difference between polyamory
and polygamist
i think one's marriage based on one is
just how many people you like
yes well what about polymorphism
what is that you [ __ ] change in
characters there's
lulu does that in in league got it got
it
cool what about polyester
multiple
okay so this throttle is
it includes a married couple the
wife is low and the husband is mike
and that was going to be low media
behind low and high
and the third one is medium i thought it
was the hierarchy in the relationship
yeah you had like a bottom and a top and
a yeah
oh my gosh all right so oh and mike oh
that sounds kind of cool
low and mike are happy if they're happy
and it works out
yeah they for a long time they had been
discussing
like introducing a third person to spice
up the bedroom
and so finally in june of 2018
they decided to have a threesome with
this girl named jess
and so after that one threesome night
they ended up discovering that they they
both have really strong feelings
was that pretty cool that was damn that
pussy's bum huh
strong connection with jess and tongue
apparently yeah
and so uh they decided that like the
married couple
they talked and then they were like you
know what we gotta keep seeing jess
she's dope so they both liked her yeah
they both liked her it's tight
and then that was actually the discovery
of lo finding out that she's bisexual
she didn't know um and so a great
discovery
every husband's dream she eats some
[ __ ] and she's like
i never knew i had an acquired taste for
this
i mean it's every husband's dream for a
little bit and then you realize there's
two women bitching at you now
so i don't see i don't you need to ruin
the fantasy i don't think guys
think that right i don't think like wait
a minute
if she's not synced with their period
i'm gonna have non-stop period wives
every [ __ ] month oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they'll sync up eventually
that's kind of like one gets off and
then not the other one and well that's
just teamwork right it gets off the
other ones pissed off
so wait maybe you don't want sync why
because then you have the other one on
your side
oh so you can like switch off yeah yeah
oh thank god then you have a team
you don't have to be the only one she's
crazy right yeah yeah
anyway so uh this
this couple became a throttle and so now
they've been together
and now they're pregnant which one
the wife is pregnant they conceived
naturally
i thought they both were pregnant they
were no no the wife is pregnant we can
do it at the same time he could come in
both
yeah he could but the the really strange
thing
and for me where i'm like how are you
gonna do that is that they're planning
on having the girlfriend jess breastfeed
the baby i'm like how should
well doesn't she have to be pregnant to
breastfeed that's what i thought
but apparently they said that she's
gonna sync up her cycle with the wife
and then something about like hormones
or
hormone therapy for it yeah like why
doesn't he just [ __ ] come in her
because she doesn't have the baby
they're just assigning
random tasks to people like you're
vacuuming the floor and they're like i
don't even have a vacuum dude
hey can't you keep can't you keep
lactating though
after you pop out a baby for like a
while as long as it's being sucked as
long as there's supply
i mean as long as there's demand they'll
be supplies there's those weird parents
that have kids sucking
at four p at four p.m four years old
because there's those nursing homes
that's just [ __ ] weird how dare they
4 p.m
yeah crazy yeah that's wild it's like
that lady in game of thrones with a
weird [ __ ] kid
yeah so i am i had never heard
of anyone like have like producing milk
yeah just because they wanted to produce
milk like i never
knew that that was possible but
apparently they're gonna attempt that
she stares at the pregnant mom just
really hard just
[Laughter]
painful if
looking at that oh they're good looking
cup truffle
from cooper so
okay this is the wife this is the
girlfriend genovia
dude their three ways probably look real
good yeah porno good right yeah
but they're married this is them
they just look like dope ass friends
that [ __ ] each other real
good for like that's basically what they
are yeah
that's basically what they are but you
don't think that these kind of things
happen because it sounds like a dream
come true
it's like you're in a couple and you're
like that couple's like a dope ass
friendship that they [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy yeah yeah this reminds
me of this reminds you like it's like
people who don't know how to have one
night stands
like they do it once they're like i have
feelings for you yeah it's like well
[ __ ] now we're in too deep now we're
pregnant that was us
but they genuinely look happy like they
don't look like instagram happy
no that's true they're not like posing
extra like
they just look like dude we [ __ ] a lot
so you look at them and now you know
they're [ __ ] kinky
oh yeah good for you guys and that's
tight but they're all like really good
looking people yeah yeah
bonus yeah but but the girlfriend to me
especially in this photo she looks a lot
younger than them she's like a teenager
yeah i'm like she brings out young
energy probably
maybe that's why because they're feeling
like older because they look
like maybe or like like like i don't
know white people
so like early 30s or some [ __ ] yeah 17
or something
no no
so the wife is 30. um i
believe the husband's 33. uh jess is 31.
well they're saying oh i wonder if
i wonder if these relationships have
ever started off non-sexually like if
it's a couple it's like
i want more romance you know instead of
just like i want to have sex with
another person i wonder if it ever
starts like
non-sexual you know what i mean what do
you mean what like what starts with
three ways
yeah instead of like the three the third
person because you know how they're
always like oh we want to try a third
person in the
bedroom yeah has it ever been just
emotional
like dinner yeah oh no just try dinner
yeah like the wife's like i want to be
romanced by a woman and see what happens
yeah i've always wondered if that's that
seems uh more
conventional if you think about it
because most people that most couples
that get together go
dinner first or you know dating before
having sex
why why wouldn't three senses start that
way i think i'd allow
like if it's like completely not because
of sex at all yeah
yeah it's like please take her out
yeah right i wanna sleep today yeah i
don't even want to be there
i don't have a trouble anymore that's
just cheating huh then what is it what
is it when you hire another company a
third party no
uh outsourcing outsourcing it's
outsourcing your response outsourcing
your husband's duties
what i mean husband for a day is for me
on my behalf
because i'm an escort no because then
she'll fall for him and she's like hey
whoa
oh is it him no i mean like i'm just
saying if you're outsourcing your
husbandly duties
yeah i don't know if it's if they don't
want it
it's part time because she could [ __ ]
fall for him all he wants but if he's
like
nah this is part time girl [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
then it's cool but if he's into her too
oh we got a problem yeah
oh yeah he's got to be thrown away he's
got to throw her away and then she runs
back to me and i'm like
i'm the best you'll ever get that's part
of the contract if she ever develops
feelings i want you to [ __ ] destroy
her heart
and then she comes back to me you gotta
hire
that's evil so evil
but yeah i don't know this couple was
saying that they like at first obviously
their families were not
you know very open-minded to it but
eventually they warmed up to especially
seeing how happy they've been together
and they're just looking forward to
raising this baby
all three of them and they're like this
baby's just gonna have like a whole
nother
set a whole nother family that loves
them more love yeah
usually that kid's gonna grow up in real
and they're gonna have to tell them like
yeah it's because we really want to [ __ ]
a third person that's why she's here
and it's just like i don't want to hear
that i know but then well maybe that
same
it could be the same idea of just like a
couple getting together right that's
true yeah
it's just a third person but the kid's
also not going to be at school and going
like
i heard my dad [ __ ] my two mommies
and people like wait what what yeah
daddy had one mommy first and then they
met another one and then both of them
loved that mommy a lot
i wonder if she'll end up having a baby
too and then also they ask like they ask
jess like
aren't you like don't you kind of feel
left out because you're not married
yeah from her perspective i'm like
wouldn't she one day wanna like
leave this nest and then and then be
married
and find find her own husband because
it's such a short time
yeah well maybe maybe the guy will
become gay
and then they'll find a husband and
they'll have a four-way
no they've only been together they met
in june of 2018. oh two
years two years now yeah two years it
seems like a really short time for such
crazy does she live with them does she
live with him or or
or she come visit because then like i
think she lives with them but she split
rent as the question oh yeah i'll buy a
boat and park it in the parking lot and
i'd live there while the girls could
live in the house
what if she just gets all the good you
just move yourself out of the house
i just don't want to be around no
females unless we're [ __ ]
out of the boat when it's in your
parking lot the idea
of getting on a boat yeah he just wants
a dry boat
plant can you please play the [ __ ] uh
like waze
all right we're out there a little bit
cool just to stick his boat in it oh
that'd be cool
that'd be kind of cool i wonder if she
would get like all the benefits
but she doesn't have to deal with like
the married life and raising the kid and
stuff well
she's going to be nursing the best
that's right so then for that
uh a quote from the article says not a
lot of women can say i'm gonna take this
shift
off and let my girlfriend breastfeed
tonight or i'm like that's kind of time
can she well that's the part that i'm
like i don't know how many people would
like
duo propose to her one day they're like
she's really cool it's been about four
years
let's both propose her don't feel extra
special
all i could think about is getting a
double blow job
yeah on your boat that's the best yeah i
can see you in the boat and you would
turn on the sprinklers just to feel like
you're on the ocean
it's splashing oh yeah that's good i
like it raise the sails
[Laughter]
can you come inside the house and [ __ ]
us sure
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right great i saw the neighbors want
to come over and give you muffins but
they're like oh no the anchor's down so
they're
the anchor's down in the driveway yeah
don't bother them don't bother
you